how's it going everyone
beer bah I'm back from a long long long
long long break why would so loud holy
crap
but anyway it feels good to be back I
hope you guys have missed me I've missed
you guys a lot and I figured I'll play
something that I know you guys want to
see a lot of people suggested zombie
escape and the reason why I whatever me
I wanted to shut down yes I have I need
to go fine
but anyway
and we're gonna play zombie escape and I
spent entire [ __ ] morning trying to
get this thing to work and if finally
finally I don't think I have time I
think you guys can see me anyway it's
not that dark
so yeah I'm excited
I'm gonna make a video like oh it
started right away perfect probably miss
the 360 yeah anyway the first yeah
tend about how I missed this little
thing two [ __ ] drawers like I'd done
that a million times
let's see
that's what she said why are you doing
what are you doing here this place is
not safe you have to get out fast how
did you get there anyways epic story is
epic I have to get out of here fast
[Music]
no let's not do that
I remember the control this new I
remember these
some nothing in them
you need a lantern
turn on to turn on by Lana I guess that
makes sense
I've had a lantern oh I miss this oh
sweet I found something
see doing [ __ ] stuff is actually good
idea
come on I totally moved
what's blocking you it's nice right
whatever
ah come on
thank you auch I gotta be kidding me
that was useless
is this
so wonder the scary parts
I should never ask that stupid question
always when you least expect
well
what was that
those are nice
we found note 3 there there's always
little text yes it is how did you find
me I wasn't supposed to find me soon
something bad bad is not good
I've traded my bad quote by the way
something bad where I like good things
I come on every freaking door this is
where I came from right yes
oh so sad that's the we're in that door
is long when the good stuff happen
I found something I'm a friggin genius
that's on the floor I'm Dean table oh
man oh yeah I can just like you know
maybe on this story I'm just guessing
because it's an inventory right no tab
come on why do I need a freaking key
then what is this Santa
is their drawer or anything
oh yeah
move the lever where's the freakin lever
oh I don't see no liver
[Music]
okay the guy's got to be this one let's
do it
oh oh I got it yeah I mean in whoa come
on
come here
[Music]
it's gotta be thought it was smart and
found the friggin gay it's gotta be some
key that's all it says
you have to get oh man I'm so clever
I'm so smart epic notes
Kennie piss off let me out let me out
why can't you use a key that way what
freaking way to use of how else do you
use a key tell me nothing
perfect
stop
stupid skies it's gotta be something to
look bad
maybe I just lay here and wait for the
penis monster
bad idea I found salt too
actually it could be a good idea
I wouldn't make this a horror movie
that's what make yourself
you know thought screw the be anyway
oh I get it
it's for the this
let's break it down
I didn't make
yeah I'm uh pissed
maybe I break this
I didn't do it it wasn't me
okay maybe why did I break that
hmm we're off to a good start I can feel
this
oh wait I didn't break this feel much
better okay
oh wait here's something no it's not
stop wasting later was in this
No
come on I would need to get out of here
[Music]
it's not even a teddy bear
is this a Peter it's obvious moment I'm
not filling in but you're sitting there
well you're supposed to do that it's a
lobbyist sir but it's not it's not
obvious
obviously
maybe something about this painting
it's nothing about the friggin baby oh I
know maybe I can fit their fat
hey there's blood here I didn't even
notice what is that it's gotta be the
key
I'm running out of frickin ideas
and why can i push this books over it's
gotta be
who glued these freakin books together
really funny
that
gonna stop cuz you're a douche
ah
oh okay which way oh let the lid off can
kill Hoffa cough cough lon
[Music]
what ha what the ah penis mother penis
was wait wait did I come from I forgot
another key and II don't have a key uh
penis monster oh so freaking door closed
[Music]
Oh
I'm not touching these anymore ah crap
ah
he's
I thought for sure he saw me man he
looks off you lost weight during the
summer
ah
No
oh he's so freaking fast is he
patrolling ah
what the [ __ ]
avoid looking at what the [ __ ]
uh-huh great mod sweetie are you serious
oh I hate that penis guy he doesn't even
have a penis I don't know why I said
that
yeah I'm ending part one here see you
tomorrow I guess